[Music]
hey guys I'm Lucy and welcome to reality
check now the idea that violent video
games are linked to aggressive or
violent behavior is obviously a bit of a
hot topic and whenever this new
scientific research in the area it
sparks a lot of media to bait on the one
side there's those that believe that
violent video games are harmless they're
just fun and it's also a way to simply
and safely blow off steam in the
confines of your own home on the other
side there's the belief that the violent
content causes gamers to become
aggressive even dangerous and that
children are being exposed to material
that simply isn't suitable for them and
so the fire was reignited last week when
the American Psychological Association
or the APA released the findings from
its latest meta-analysis now
meta-analysis is just a fancy term for
when psychologists combined the findings
from multiple studies in a particular
research area to help identify trends
and relationships the APA is the world's
largest organization representing
psychology and its mission as they put
it is to advance the creation
communication and application of
psychological knowledge to benefit
society and improve people's lives so
when its meta-analysis results were sent
out and accompanied with the provocative
press release headline APA review
confirms link between playing violent
video games and aggression people paid
attention as someone who plays games and
has a degree in psychology I was
naturally quite interested to see how
they came to their conclusions so I
decided to delve into the 49 page report
to find out whether their conclusions
had any merit and to examine any
possible media fallout or misconceptions
and yeah there have been some of those
but to understand how this report came
about we need to go back in time to 2005
the year of hot coffee Elijah Wood
announcing the Xbox 360 and the APA
announcing its official stance its
resolution on violent video games based
on research in the area it concluded
that violent games can increase
aggressive behavior in both children and
adolescence let's fast forward then to
2013 to ensure that its stance was
informed by the best science currently
available the APA set up a task force to
review the latest literature but the
appointment of this task force caused a
bit of a commotion in the psychological
community speaking recently to Game
Informer Chris Ferguson a psychology
professor from Stetson University
mentioned that all seven members of the
APA task force were over the age of 50
now that sounds a gist but then Ferguson
said that there's actually a lot of
literature suggesting that older people
generally have more negative views of
modern media like video games not only
that but two members previously and
publicly supported government attempts
to censor sales of m-rated games in the
state of California now it's not to say
that the task force were acting
unprofessionally but it is worth noting
that their ages and their existing
viewpoints on video games deserve
scrutiny in fact in 2013 Ferguson and
over 200 of his peers wrote an open
letter expressing concerns about the
task force and its methodology they
claimed that the 2005 resolution the APA
was revising was actually based on weak
and inconsistent evidence and warned of
publication bias in the open letter
Ferguson explains that such rigid policy
statements like the EPA's resolution may
inadvertently serve to increase
publication bias particularly giving
concerns about both disregard for null
findings and researcher degrees of
freedom
he then referenced research conducted by
Simmons Nelson and Simonson which
suggested that researchers are more
likely to falsely find evidence that an
effect exists than to correctly find
evidence that it does not think about
what gets picked up in the media a
middle-of-the-road study that shows no
real correlation between two variables
isn't going to grab headlines like one
that presents a cause and effect
relationship as definitive and the media
can't use video games as scapegoats
based on maybes so there may be hundreds
of studies that haven't been considered
by the task force purely because they
weren't published by a journal due to
the fact their findings weren't
conclusive which would mean that the
voices of those people saying myth it's
hard to tell are being drowned out by
the louder voices saying yes
is definitely a relationship let's
summarize them the APA threw together a
task force headed up by people who some
suspect had anti-gay leanings to review
the APS inconclusive 2005 stance that
violent video games can heighten
aggressive behavior amongst children now
we know the foundations of the task
force let's talk about their report at
this stage it's really important to note
that in the foreword to their report the
task force actually used one of Chris
Ferguson's papers as evidence that
violent videogames lead to aggressive
outcomes but Ferguson study didn't show
that it actually suggests that any
conclusions drawn regarding the
relationship between violent video games
and aggressive behavior are affected by
bias in the research this is a key point
we need to consider when we look at any
research in this field the task force
has been criticized by Chris Ferguson
and other psychologists for failing to
include evidence that rejects the claim
the violent video games promote
aggression studies like Gunther and
Daley who suggested that the
relationship had been overestimated or
this study by Giamatti and Maki which
showed that those with crinkly
personality traits were more affected by
violent video games than those who don't
have those same traits suggesting that
the relationship is far more complicated
than what the task force was actually
testing for now these emissions could be
due to the strict inclusion criteria
that the task force set their sources
for example had to come from
peer-reviewed scientific journals which
again makes finding susceptible to
publication bias by not including these
studies and there were a lot of them
that weren't included it could be argued
that there has been a failure of due
diligence which is crucial for a study
making a statement on an important
social issue in fact in their
meta-analysis the task force only
actually compared the results from 18
out of the total 31 studies that met
their inclusion criteria and when it
comes to the statistical results meta
analyses frequently use averages and in
some cases they make estimates Ferguson
and his peers noted in their open letter
that by doing this you can effectively
smooth over Incans
results a study that shows a negligible
effect can be effectively canceled out
in a meta-analysis by a study that shows
a large one and by focusing on the
relationship between only two variables
in this case while and video game use
and aggression the APA are ignoring
crucial environmental and personal
factors which all come together to form
a conclusion that's too complicated to
package into a hot button headline it's
broadly understood that human behavior
is governed by multiple factors and not
just one so to pin down cause-and-effect
we need to take all of these things into
consideration but as you can imagine
this is no simple task there's so much
to take into account gender
socioeconomic status personality traits
and just how to even standardize video
game violence that is a whole other can
of worms and one that I'm gonna open up
in the next episode of reality check I
don't have to tell you how important
this kind of psychological research is
we live in an age where video games are
a part of everyday life we are exposed
to them along with other forms of
violent media more than ever
the scientific community has an
obligation to the general public to
investigate the effects of such material
so join me next time on reality check as
I delve headfirst into the stormy sea
that is violent video game research in
the meantime if you're interested in the
topic why not check out Danny's episode
of the point where he weighs in on the
role of the games press in the violent
video game debate or this episode of the
what-if machine which was the early name
for reality check where cam investigated
the effects of video game violence
so there's your extra reading thanks for
watching guys don't forget that I'm on
Twitter at Lucy James games and I'll see
you next time for some more reality
check
[Music]